y efectivamente en esto no es esto no es
algo fuera de lo habitual en esta zona
de nigeria de hecho en la última década
las redes criminales en principio no
tendrían que ver con con grupos
yihadistas o terroristas han matado a
más de 8000 personas y han provocado más
de 200.000 desplazamientos forzosos
el secuestro es una de las principales
fuentes de financiación suelen pedir
rescate por por todos estos civiles
secuestrados pero
efectivamente como comentabas el
secuestro de qantara supuso un
importante cambio cualitativo en esto ya
que por primera vez relacionado con boko
haram fuera del estado de borno está en
la otra punta del país y es donde los
terroristas suelen suelen operar así es
marta ahora me pregunto por qué si estos
secuestros no son algo nuevo que ocurre
en nigeria como les estábamos comentando
porque el gobierno toma medidas
contundentes para que esto deje de
suceder o en menor cantidad menor medida
si hasta ahora la principal problemática
en la que el gobierno se ha centrado ha
sido en el terrorismo yihadista que está
de liderado bueno por las dos facciones
de boko haram la del seca y la fina
estado islámico y entonces sus esfuerzos
se han estado concentrando en esa lucha
en el extremo noreste del país y los
bandidos pues han seguido operando con
relativa impunidad en la zona centro y
en la zona oeste lo que pasa que durante
el último año esta problemática ha ido
ha ido empeorando los ataques se han
recrudecido y ha habido una mayor
presión social que ya finalmente con la
implicación oficial de boko haram en el
secuestro de can cara o sí que ha
provocado un mayor despliegue de las
fuerzas de seguridad en esta zona centro
y occidental pero ya te digo que esto
pues llevan son redes criminales que
llevan por lo menos diez años operando
allí son realmente fuertes entonces no
es nada fácil de combatir ahora